ein entwickler drei spiele einmal müssen
sie springen einmal müssen sie fallen
einmal müssen sie kämpfen heute müssen
sie kämpfen
hier bin ich wieder mit der dritten
episode dieser trilogie triologie
betrieb rede papst triologie oder als
trilogie hieß das bei der hobbit weil
das eine trilogie oder triathlet
herzlich willkommen zur dreiteiligen
serie die aus den spielen besteht spiel
namens majors im titel lesen könnt und
ich vergesse immer dass sie das ganze ja
eh schon eingeblendet erweitert ja so
cool mit dem comedian download geht an
simples spielprinzip oben kommt ein
wurfmesser unten kommt ein wurfmesser
immer abwehren
mein highscores zwölf freunde und den
werde ich jetzt ob direkt dringlicher 14
nach dem punkte 10 520 8 erfolgreichen
mission wir so eine scheiße motion in
schwarz weiß mit jetzt
ich mach jetzt neuen highschool immer
wenn ich singe fangen wir doch noch zu
drehen weil ich ich ich kann nicht sehen
meine augen liegt aus auf die trinken
kann das nicht was ein [ __ ]
ich war meine augen an ich bin ich mir
immer wenn ich irgendwie anfange zu
singen singen kriege ich total so rote
augen und total
ihr wisst was ich meine babys das ist
einfach so schön wer nicht sehen muss
ich unbedingt anfangen zu heulen alter
ich habe tränen im auge woher kommen die
ich kann nicht sehen hier nahezu
weltweit augen sowie tun ich musste die
ganze zeit klimpern er jetzt bin ich tot
sieht man das war ich kurz zur kamera
nicht aber die sind extrem so so dumme
meine meine videos hier werden echt
immer dümmer das schreiben auch letzten
welche kommentare die hochwertige jetzt
nur noch schwach den broadcast yourself
freunde ich kann machen was ich will ich
könnte mich auch nackt ausziehen und ich
mache drittel in übung sprache diesem
spiel geht es halt echt man kann
wirklich nur nach oben gucken weiß ganz
genau was man nach unten drücken muss
ohne zu sterben
lieferando de kennen wir ja schon ja
hallo hier sieht der contractor ruhig
die 2000 pizzen ohne zwiebeln dann ja
dann nehme ich dann auch noch 20
hamburger genau ohne diät cola aber ich
bin auf diät
genau dann kommt das in fünf minuten an
ok spitze mit mit 20 autos kommen sie
dann auch mit 20 lkw flugzeug brauchen
verbraucher alte jurist aus dem flugzeug
rauswerfen
ok dann sehen wir uns dann gleich auf
dem dach ok usc kontrakten
kameraperspektive voll gesehen hast du
gar nicht telefoniert astral kräfte ist
voll mit real und guck mir schon die
ganze wieder lincoln an und steht vor
seiner
industrialisierten stadt nach dem ersten
weltkrieg in amerika und will eine neue
sampler aufbauen lichtjahre kann ja
überhaupt nichts mit solchen spielen
anfangen forged of empires ist es
bestimmt genau so ein schwachsinn wie
die siedler oder so obwohl ich die
siedler damals echt cool fahren viel
gespielt habe ich habe danach richten
werde eins mit dem spiel lukas mit dem
spiel übrigens haben wir auch einige
leute geschrieben dass diese wir haben
halt auch viele geschrieben dass das
spiel bei youtube liegt das ist bei mir
allerdings so wenn ich das hier spiele
es läuft alles total weich also flüssig
was aber wenn ich das bearbeite ist auch
alles total flüssig also irgendwie macht
youtube in dieses spiel ich weiß ja dass
wegen den wenigen farben ist oder was
weiß ich warum macht das ab und zu so
alle zehn sekunden mal so einen kleinen
hänger rein dass das dann einfach mal
kurz ein standbild ist aber bei mir
läuft alles flüssig also jetzt nicht so
dass das sie mit russland aufnehmen
sollte ich wieder sinken keine gute idee
ich lass das lieber ich las dass diese
videos erhalten wo ich so scheint es
mache aber das war total komisches gehen
irgendwie das war kein normales gehen
mein mund musste einfach irgendwie auf
gemacht werden der chef will eine peri
um das ist bei diesen spielen halt immer
der fall dass man unglaublich gerne
weiterspielen möchte weil man einfach
seinen eigenen highscore verbessern will
das sind eigentlich so totale spiele so
forever in sachen einfach ich glaube
sogar bei solchen spielen wenn man
richtig gut wenn man das einfach zu
zweit spielt irgendwie dieses major
empfiehlt jetzt hier gerade ist
perfekter für einer konzentriert sich
nur auf den roten der andere auf dem
blauen und dann drückt man irgendwie
wenn ich das mit dem spielen würde wäre
ich trotzdem diejenige person wegen der
attacken würden aber wayne freunde davon
jetzt eben kurz neuen highscore ich weiß
doch gar nicht mehr was war denn der
andere eisflächen hat mir überhaupt was
muss ich denn überhaupt schaffen aber
das ist richtig fies die teile kommen
jetzt viel schneller man muss voll
abpassen kann man jetzt schlägt alle das
ist doch locker schon neuer hai skoda
ist das neuen highscore wenn das neue
ryse größe ähnlich dann hat das video
das neue high score
und 2
das cool ist halt was youtuber mit
partner kräften alles machen können
zeige ich euch mal eben und zwar kann
ich einmal schnitzen und zack habe ich
den hunderttausendfache an highscore ja
ich hab jetzt 4,6 millionen wenn ihr das
toppen sollte dann schreibt mir die
kommentare ich würde sagen dass war es
mit der serie make them irgendwann waren
ja drei spielern ich habe jetzt so
gemacht wenn ihr weitere apps habt die
ich eventuell mal anzocken sollte dann
schreibt zu runden dauert die kommentare
und dann die wir uns